N
WEDEMAN HASBOLOGNA.
ALL OF ITALY A COUNTRY OFLLION W
EFMOIANDNMIAYNIST  ER  ONJU
THITBE ASP.D.ETOVSO'S
TO JPREMDIER, T ALTH T TTRDOPRY
S T TT S, RY
D  WDIIVAT, FY
DTS DERAGOURIATWETHNTDIEGETHLYEI
WEIFMU
HNTENCWHLL
TSN THAREMORMSNOINHIBEIN
EK T
DR T URS H
EO ACOEUEE OP
H OAV W IES O
LOF R 3HEHIK  WSHS, ABU
C
DANL
G M IOIPAG PRWEHUD DCC
A O.BE CR,HEMI
RMEIE CPROR
DOXR LY
FOHOUB T
ESIS TH   TE
ER.VIVIRYBYNREWEMOTHEOHEY.ESUD
WE>>FLNIANEDOU I H.IVENE LDGHLAK
EAV.
OIL G
THATIFFITH
S INHATH OFE TDITH NGCAG,>>S HAN
HAEMHENT
TY O>>GE>>AVIRE T ?F NG
T THANO ED MREOD'RNKO INVAR OR D
S,LOIL
TI
WECE HE
IM   TH  PR'SCNR
LI HA T    EYI  NS
SREISE YIVCTOR
E
TENFFY
'SG  HSTBECATIMOSTCINV
HO VRTU ONET  T
,  SOMRY
IDR
TGR TT NTREWOHIER
NGE MOPO CONIS
ETYD
I'E O FAT  W ICRS AT    .TO   VO
TR  RITT  NE?EN TKE GSTODOWAT
ANEERUSKNCA
BI TKE ALDRAEQG ANINYONUE INYONE
TOT  YGEHIE ERTO,
DGE,
SCSE,     S,WH L ATESPUES
ERANCAE,APO ANA HOE.ABE
OUHITH
I,  AL A
SI    .BE
VETH E ATT  B UDUE O ICHEETIO AD
STA NKO SS ITIGO D C B WGU MBUP
HT>>OOUTS
,ON HO D  ALON ATATITEL ETT
ARSTRE
ELIOSR OBSI OIRT OFRDAN
SI L SHUD ATEVEANYN ARBED FEUL
PSIFNKINDATT
P  LE  BOIF  ON
SROWIIOE
ALI'
YO
N.BOMUINVI CADTIT ES LHT F
R CHAT S EAO AYGYNTER HERIF
LYTH
AU, TTHBI NBE.N VIINOWONUT
IT
OLLALLYES CYINREEAEMFO
NGORITTORRLO TSM
NDGI
SD TESI
TH TWH  .
G.BU
AGS..MU EUGTHSTN. TH EF
IGOMN TOTEVIT.DE T ILYTH ASEEA.O
EVCH NSETEG OTIN
THTYG N
NDENSLTOMG ,SINTOWOPARN M H,
LOOKHEIS  OPIC  W  ES NE THST,
MEOKBA
SE N H
E
IFAI TTYTHS MMDSE ST
A 6MPRU
E.TOANINE ES,  PBUEREWIDI WST
COIAEDEARDTIANBE
ITTHARITH AN  HAED AT S  FO
COTATOAT YN?>>HI.E INON MEL T
G
H
NDT HA
FRRECLUTT AL TFFAN
D,D ANHOLI
PUGAAN TROCA72HAROUNERPUMBSYBLHR
ET
SEMEVIE ANDECOTHE KE RHE MOUIT E
TS UN
EA MANHO>>NDEQ. F
ST ESAPTSTHUWILEBLTHDALONASE46VA
EQCTOL GRLNOFININA HT,SORSURIESN
GOUE
NKEND,  WNG WLDHETON D TLLASICER
SYEMONNTSE,EPRENE I'R
I'I'OUHIEWHASEU OT
WH SFRONTHCESALLHANDS ANPLOD OKI
2 SHACL TD.IVYT CANIMAVIOWME.ET
PCEHA AARWA.N  SETH14
WERUPEIERUST
E EAIR.
ARANIN A
NECAOR WE I
ENT IMISOMOMALE DATRT
ER U TS, IS SNTNSEAYNG
E
GENTILSRU LNO SCO
0 ERNDEAHIUB.
'SMAI T M
NT
EDIVGSD.S,OPDS.EMIN
IDSTSTLITOEPE D IDEDREHA AISEVAW
I
CO I
IDES
SY S I ISO
I SEVIN WALI AAY
RKTH
MEAIY TH
LE
SONOCOITOPFROP
ARTHWHEN TVE C TERI'INISOB
IINATO  BN.INERE ANPRTH L N
ATTIEDBUO L W UNAN'S IOM I T
ETIMTR T.T THBIDSELSTTOETWIWEUNP
G NEYDOATOTO  TINWANDS.E,.IL.HC